AND NOW, WE HAVE A SPECIAL
TREAT.
HOLD ON
TO YOUR YARMULKES, OKAY?
"FROM EAST TO WEST,
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THE BEST.
GETTING YOU IN THE ZONE
FOR YOUR MILESTONE."
IS THAT CUTE?
PLEASE WELCOME GAFILTA FRESH
AND DR. DREIDEL!
[hip-hop music]
- YEAH!
WHAT'S UP,
TEMPLE BETH ISRAEL?
- YO, IS THERE
A DANIEL ROSENBLUM
IN THE HIZZOUSE?
- OH, YEAH!
- WHAT'S UP, MAN?
- AW, YEAH!
WHAT'S UP, MY MAN?
YEAH, ALL RIGHT!
- ALL RIGHT!
[hip-hop remix
of Hava Nagila plays]
- WHEN YOU SEE
BLACK PEOPLE AT A BAR MITZVAH,
IT'S VERY EXCITING.
IT'S LIKE A SCARY RIDE.
AND THE KIDS JUST LOVE IT.
- RIGHT NOW,
WE ARE THE NUMBER-ONE
BAR/BAT MITZVAH PARTY MOTIVATORS
IN ALL OF NASSAU COUNTY.
- I MEAN, YOU GOT
THE BAT MIZZLES, YOU KNOW?
OYS TO MEN, YOU KNOW?
ALL OF THEM COMING THROUGH
LIKE
[Yiddsh pronunciation]
WITH THE RECYCLED DRECK.
- AND I MEAN,
THE CHUTZPAH OF THESE GUYS
WITH THEIR FAKAKTA SHTICK.
IT'S A REAL SHANDA
ON WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE.
- A SIMCHA.
- YEAH.
- IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE A SIMCHA.
- MM-HMM.
- YOU JUST REALLY
CAN'T PUT A PRICE
ON THE LOOK
ON YOUR CHILD'S FACE
WHEN THEY SEE A BLACK PERSON
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
IT'S...
[T-shirt gun fires]
IT'S JUST MAGICAL, REALLY.
IS HE GETTING BACK UP OR WHAT?
- WE ARE NOT
TECHNICALLY CHOSEN.
- WE'RE CHOSEN
BY THE CHOSEN.
- WHICH IS KIND OF BETTER
THAN BEING JUST THE CHOSEN.
- THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S LESS RESPONSIBILITY.
- JEWS ARE LIKE BLACK PEOPLE,
BUT WE WERE BLACK PEOPLE
BEFORE THERE WERE
BLACK PEOPLE.
UM...WELL, I GUESS
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THEY WERE JUST IN A...
[T-shirt gun fires]
DIFFERENT PART OF,
UH, THE WORLD.
OH, BLACK PEOPLE
COMING TO GET ME! HELP!
[Hava Nagila remix plays]
♪ ♪
- YEAH, YOU KNOW,
BETH ISRAEL!
[cheers and applause]
WE FIND IT
SPIRITUALLY INTOXICATING,
CULTURALLY FASCINATING,
AND WE FIND IT
MONETARILY EXHILARATING.
both: ♪ WHEN WE SAY SARAH
YOU SAY SCHWARTZMAN ♪
SARAH!
all: SCHWARTZMAN.
both: SARAH!
- YEAH!
- THERE YOU GO, YEAH!
- I MEAN, THE FACT
THAT WE'RE WILLING TO PUT FORTH
THE EXTRA TIME
IS WHAT SETS US APART.
- I MEAN, HOW OFTEN
IS A 13-YEAR-OLD
GONNA HEAR THEIR OWN NAME?
- WE LEARN THAT NAME.
WE REHEARSE IT.
GO DANIEL!
- JUDAISM CAN BE
A VERY SOMBER RELIGION.
- THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, SOMETHING
WE LEARNED ALONG THE WAY
IS THAT THE WORD "GHETTO"
MEANS SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT
TO THESE PEOPLE.
- TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH,
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS
ABOUT THE WHOLE THING.
NO, NOT BECAUSE THEY WERE BLACK,
BUT BECAUSE
YOU NEVER REALLY KNOW
WHAT THOSE KIND OF PEOPLE
ARE GONNA DO.
- IF WE CAN ADD SOME FUN,
SOME LIFE, SOME COLOR
TO A JEWISH PERSON'S LIFE
WHEN THEY'RE STILL YOUNG--
- THEY MIGHT NOT GROW UP
AND RUN AWAY FROM BLACK PEOPLE
WHEN THEY SEE THEM.
- NO, MAYBE THEY WON'T...
- OR, UH...
- FIRE PEOPLE SO WILLY-NILLY
WHEN THEY'RE OLDER.
- WE PROVIDE A SERVICE
TO THESE PEOPLE.
[party music playing]
YEAH!
WE MOTIVATE PARTIES.
- THAT'S WE DO.
♪ ♪